pues vamos a seguir factor izando y en
esta ocasión quiero factorizar 35 k
cuadrada más 100 k menos 15 y bueno como
te das cuenta al lado de la cuadrada no
hay un 1 por lo tanto lo primero que
podemos pensar es en factorizar esto por
agrupación sin embargo hay que tener
cuidado porque aquí todos estos tienen
un factor común y tal vez sacamos de una
vez el factor común pueda ser que aquí
nos quede un 1 o inclusive puede ser que
nos quede la expresión mucho más fácil
de factorizar porque imagínate buscar
los números que multiplicados me den 35
x menos 15 eso se ve un poco grande
entonces lo más que se puede actualizar
de aquí es un 55 que multiplicar bueno
en primer lugar a 7 acá cuadrada y
después es 100 entre 5000 a 20 entonces
más 20 acá y después menos 15 entre 5 me
dan menos tres menos tres y si te das
cuenta 7 20 menos 3 no tienen nada en
común por lo tanto el coeficiente que
está al lado de la cuadrada es 7 y
entonces para qué yo factor este la
expresión que tengo aquí adentro lo que
tengo que pensar es en factorizar por
agrupación
para eso tengo que buscar dos números
que su multiplicación me den la
multiplicación de siete por menos tres a
por b tiene que ser siete por menos tres
recuerda que multiplicamos este y este
de aquí entonces me va a dar 7 x menos 3
lo cual me da menos 21 y también a más
ve los mismos números me tienen que dar
este de aquí en medio a más bay tiene
que ser igual a 20 que es el coeficiente
que está al lado de la cama muy bien dos
números que multiplicados me den menos
21 y sumados mete en 20 y como ya hemos
visto no olvides el consejo que siempre
te doy si la multiplicación de estos dos
números es negativa entonces uno tiene
que ser positivo y el otro tiene que ser
negativo y por lo tanto cuando me estoy
tomando la suma entre estos dos
realmente me estoy tomando la diferencia
de estos dos números y si te das cuenta
si yo me tomo 21 positivo y uno negativo
me dan los valores que cumplen estas
ecuaciones al mismo tiempo 20 y menos 1
porque 20 x menos 1 norma 20 x menos una
persona cierto es 21 x menos 1 perdón es
que ando un poco confundido 21 x menos 1
me da su multiplicación menos 21
1 - 1 me da de resultado 20 es más los
podemos sumar 21 menos 1 es lo mismo que
20 aquí están dos números que sumados me
dan 20 y dos números que multiplicados
me da menos 21 piénsalo y bueno por lo
tanto ahora que yo quiero pensar en cómo
voy a factorizar esta expresión lo que
tengo que hacer es romper esta expresión
de la siguiente manera lo que voy a
hacer es romper el 20 acá y en lugar de
poner 20 acá lo que voy a poner es 21 k
menos 1 acá entonces déjame ponerlo aquí
en lugar de este de aquí voy a poner más
21 camps y después menos 1 cam menos
camps es lo mismo el 1 de estudio
metiendo y después menos 35 que
multiplica a 7 acá cuadrada más 21 que
menos acá menos 3 y lo que hice fue
romper este 20 cap porque a continuación
lo que voy a hacer es factorizar esto
por agrupación y recuerda que para
factorizar en agrupación lo que tengo
que hacer es buscar grupos me voy a
fijar en el primer grupo que tengo aquí
es decir 7 acá cuadrada más 21 camps y
de aquí voy a factorizar lo más que se
pueda que 7 campo y este 7 acá la quema
multiplicada
7 k cuadrado en 37 kameda cam y después
21 k / 7 kaman edad 3 positivos la k con
la que se cancelan y 21 en 37 m 3 y
después me voy a fijar en el siguiente
grupo mi siguiente grupo es esto que
tengo aquí y te aquí voy a factorizar lo
más que se pueda y si te das cuenta los
dos tienen menos por lo tanto voy a
actualizar un menos uno menos uno que
multiplica acá y menos entre menos me va
a dar más es decir acá más 3 menos uno
que multiplica acá más tres y todo esto
está multiplicado por cinco no vayas a
olvidar este 5 porque podría ser un
error fatal al resolver un examen bueno
ya que tengo este 5 ahora lo que voy a
hacer es fijarme aquí adentro y darme
cuenta que estos dos tienen como factor
común el camas 3 recuerda que el segundo
paso de la factorización por agrupación
es buscar de esta expresión que tengo
aquí quién es mi factor común y sacarlo
y si te das cuenta es el binomio camas 3
camas 3 que va a multiplicar a quién
bueno en primer lugar multiplica a 7 que
es este 7 que tengo aquí fíjate que 7
camps en primer lugar multiplica
3 y después a menos 1 que es este menos
1 que tengo aquí menos 1 que a su vez
multiplica más 3 y no estoy haciendo
nada raro en imagen nada del otro mundo
lo único que quiero que veas es que
estas dos expresiones son equivalentes y
distribuyó el k más 3 y bueno no
olvidemos este 5 y no voy a poner los
paréntesis porque ya no son necesarios y
perfecto lo hemos actualizado lo hemos
hecho